all right I would like to thank Emily
and say
and Perry for organizing yet a wonderful
conference I hope you are enjoying
yourselves I can testify that the
speakers are enjoying themselves it's a
rare occasion for us to to get together
and hear each other talk I will be
talking today about mentalization in BPD
from bench to bedside and as Emily said
when she introduced the speakers early
this morning I will be talking a lot of
bench
so I'll be presenting quite a bit of
science but I'm hoping to really draw it
through to the translational endpoint of
bench to bedside to also give you some
sense of mentalization in the context of
bedside and when I present data I'm
really going to try and focus on
adolescents with borderline personality
disorder to stick with a theme of today
so what do we mean with bench-to-bedside
what we really mean is translational
research the official definition is the
effective translation of new knowledge
mechanisms and techniques generated by
advances in basic science research into
approaches for prevention diagnosis and
treatment of disease and so what we do
in translational researchers we take
discoveries in basic science and we
translate that into be useful in
clinical practice now because this is
such a worthwhile endeavor the NIH
founded several clinical translational
science centers in order to further this
agenda and you can see there that quite
a bit of money has been spent on these
translational research centers however
just a small portion of that funding has
gone to mental health so only about
three hundred and twenty million dollars
out of nearly four billion dollars have
gone to mental health in trying to
establish a translational research base
for treating mental disorders and at the
bottom of this
mental health focus is personality
disorders so it brings up the question
why is it that there is this lack of
focus in translational research for
personality disorder and for mental
health in general and when we start
unpacking the criteria for translational
research it becomes apparent how
difficult it is to do good translational
research so I'm going to stand still
just a little bit at what are the
criteria for translational research and
we'll understand why it's so hard to do
this in personality disorder research so
the first criterion is that
translational research need to be from
bench to bedside so we need to develop
all of these tools and mechanisms in
basic science and then we have to
translate it to clinical practice but it
has to work the other way around too we
have to take ideas that come from
clinical practice and we have to
translate them back to the bench and use
them to inform work at the bench
discoveries in translational research is
not always biological in nature and
related to the third point there
grigorenko talks about healthy
reductionism so translational research
is not all about reducing what we do in
clinical practice down to biological
mechanisms it also takes into account
interactions between the environment and
biology a fourth criterion of
translational research is that it has to
be interdisciplinary so we have to have
a conceptual model that can guide the
interdisciplinary nature of
translational research and we have to
have a construct that can move easily
between disciplines so having a
construct that cannot be easily talked
about in biology and cannot be then
translated into clinical practice is a
problem for translational research the
integration of biology does need to
happen we want to see that this
construct can be studied across multiple
levels of analysis from cells to neural
networks through to behavioral
phenotypes and through to our clinical
interventions good translational workers
always developmental and the reason why
the NIH has decreed that it should be
developmental is because we know that
the earlier we intervene the more effect
our treatment and our interventions have
so good translational research has to be
downwardly extended to children and
adolescents development of pathways to
personalized medicine is another
criteria for translational research we
have to be able to in translational
research work out what works for whom so
we have to be able to have a construct
that we study that we can look at in the
context of mediators and moderators does
this work for men does this work for
women does this work for older people
does it work for younger people so again
a flexibility in the construct that we
identify for the translational research
that can move easily across development
and across different types of
populations related to that it has to be
a construct that we can study in typical
populations and in a typical populations
so we have to find constructs for
translational research where we can pick
up differences between healthy people
but also differences between people who
have problems and then between those two
groups
finally translational research must lead
to measures or instruments that are off
the shelf and that we can use to track
outcome and treatment so there's no use
in identifying something at the bench
that we then translate into our
treatment that we then can't
operationalize in our treatment to track
treatment outcome so you can see
translational medicine requires a lot
from psychiatry in order to make itself
relevant in the context of translational
research if we put all of this into a
model this is what you see you've got a
disorder there at the top you want to be
able to look at genetic variables that
associate with that disorder so that's
really at the bottom end of
the translational spectrum you really
want to translate those genetic
variables into a neurobiological in the
phenotype so that will be for instance a
brain circuit you want to be able to
then further translate that into
neurocognitive in the phenotype so that
will be what neuropsychologist tests
when they do testing with patients you
next want to translate that into a
behavioral phenotype you want to be able
to describe the behavior perhaps through
a questionnaire based measure and then
you want to be able to translate that
into it therapeutic target that you can
talk to clinicians about that they need
to go target in their interventions and
so forth in addition we acknowledge that
all of this is influenced by the
environment there's going to be an
interaction with the environment with a
cycle it has to be relevant across
development in typical and atypical
populations and finally it has to have
the outcome of measures of malleable
treatment targets so there needs to be a
pragmatic outcome here that people can
use off-the-shelf so a tall order for
psychiatry and as you can imagine there
are not many constructs in psychiatry
that have been successful at this I'm
going to just give you in as an example
one construct that has probably been
most successful in context of depression
and that's a reward function we know
that there are certain genetic
associations with reward function in the
brain that's specific to depression we
know that we can put people in an fMRI
scanner and we'll see you reduce
societal responses in their brains we
know that that is associated with
reduced reward if we give them
neuropsych testing we know that we can
give them the behavioral activation
scale at the behavioral phenotype and we
can get that raw behavioral phenotype in
the form of anhedonia we know then that
we can target behavioral activation in
our therapies and we therefore completed
this translational model for depression
through focusing on this treatment
target of reward function so that's just
to give you an idea of what we're
shooting for in personality disorder
research and borderline personality so
in particular so what I'm going to do in
the rest of the talk is I'm gonna
evaluate where the mentalization has
potential as a translational target so
I'm gonna look at what do we know about
mentalizing that's far and I'm gonna
evaluate whether mentalizing can
actually function as a translational
target in this sense I'll be talking
naturally about some of the work we've
been doing but I'm also going to touch
on some of the work that comes out of
other labs and I hope to really end at
this therapeutic target point over there
does this work there we go and and
really give you a sense of the of the
full translational spectrum as we go
along alright so just briefly a
mentalization has been used in the
psychoanalytic literature since 1970s
according to some reports even earlier
and there it was defined as the process
of mental elaboration including
symbolization which leads to the
transformation and elaboration of drive
effect experiences as mental phenomena
and structures so quite dense language
to really get to the point that we are
people with minds and that the mind
means something that we can look to the
mind to create meaning and to make sense
of what happens to us this concept is
then picked up in the 1990s this is
certainly when I started working in this
area it was first picked up in the
developmental literature and then picked
up in the neuroscience literature and
therefore started gaining mainstream
status often used interchangeably with a
concept a theory of mind which refers to
the capacity to interpret behavior with
inner mentalistic framework to ascribe
thoughts and feelings ideas and
intentions to others and to employ this
ability to anticipate and influence
behavior so mentalization is slightly
broader than theory of mind because as
Arrieta said earlier on it also includes
reflection on your own mind and not just
the mind of the other person but also
reflecting on what's happening between
two people I think that's what social
neuroscience is trying to do right now
is trying to work out what what happens
within the space between two people in
CBT we've often looked at social
cognition but it's usually a property of
the individual rather than a property of
the relationship what mentalization does
is it takes it out of two people and
looks at the space between two people
and trying to reflect on what happens
there with both minds in mind all right
so first criterion translational
research needs to be multidisciplinary
and what I've done in this slide is
simply simply list the fields that are
studying mentalization so psychoanalysis
molecular genetics behavioral genetics
biology developmental psychology
neuroscience developmental cognitive
neuroscience mirror economics I'll talk
a little bit about that later again near
economics is where behavioral economic
tasks are used in concert with fMRI in
order to study social interaction
psychiatry clinical psychology
developmental psychopathology where I
find myself home and family therapy so
with regard to this first criterion we
see mentalization does have potential
because it's a construct that can be
used seemingly effective effectively in
multiple disciplines as I said
translational research needs to work
from bedside to bench as well as from
bench to bedside I'm going to spend a
lot of time on bench debate sites I just
briefly want to talk about bedside to
bench mentalization as we know it today
in in the context of mediation based
therapy really was packaged for the
first time by Peter Fornetti in 89 and
in 1991 when he for the first time wrote
about it in the context of borderline
personality disorder which then
stimulated the bench work that I'm going
to talk about next so according to this
second criteria then that mainly is that
a construct needs to be able to work
from from beta Bane from Bates
occupation by
from bench to bedside we see
mentalization does have its birth at at
the bedside really and then really
stimulating the bench work afterwards so
getting into bench to bedside then
really talking about multidisciplinarity
a theory of mind as I said has its
origins in evolutionary psychology where
it was studied for the first time with
shrimpanzees Premack and Woodruff
coining the term theory of mine in 1978
so the first task as it were was
developed in evolutionary psychology the
first task of mentalization we then
seeded the developmental psychologists
developing tasks this is the sally-ann
task that was published 1983 by Wimmer
and Poorna which was then picked up by
the autism researchers to show that
individuals with autism have
difficulties in theory of mind as well
as younger children children before the
age of 4 had difficulty passing the the
traditional theory of mind task we then
make see tasks are being developed in
other disciplines like near economics
this is a classic behavioral economics
task I'll talk more about that a bit
later but this is then picked up by
researchers in borderline personality
disorder in order to study social
interaction in BPD so we see this
development of tasks that people are
starting to translate that it comes from
developmental psychology from basic
behavioral neuroscience and from
evolutionary psychology and researchers
in the that have clinical interests of
picking up these tasks and transporting
it over into the clinical realm the
tasks that I want to standstill at for a
moment is the movie assessment for
social cognition again a basic science
task that was developed at the Max
Planck Institute in Berlin and it's it's
shown as a video I break it down like
this because I don't always trust that
things will go OK research participants
are given this video takes about 15
minutes if you were to play it from
beginning to end
but it gets stopped along the way so we
tell people you will be watching a 15
minute film please watch very carefully
and try to understand what each
character is feeling or thinking you'll
meet each character there's a sound
this is Betty this is cliff and this is
Michael the film shows these four people
getting together for the Saturday
evening the movie will be stopped at
various points and some questions will
be asked all of the answers a multiple
choice and require one option to be
selected from a choice of four if you
answer if you're not exactly sure
please case when you answer try to
imagine what the characters are thinking
of feeling at the very moment the film
is stopped so you will see people will
see this in vivo and the first scene for
instance is a young woman she's
attractive she's named Sandra she opens
the door upon opening the door a man who
looks to be around the same age enters
the house and before she can really
answers he compliments her on her hair
and he shakes that she looks terrific
she then touches her hair and starts to
say something again but he compliments
her again that she that her he looks
very classy and you don't get the
benefit of seeing the full video but
perhaps some of you can just go by by
her expression in her face I sometimes
let people guess which one it is but I
won't do that today so so the research
participant then chooses a her hair does
not look that nice now if you think
about that in the question what is
Sandra feeling and that would be
considered a no mentalizing response
because it really doesn't make use of
mental state language and it's really
far removed from understanding what
really is happening between these two
people B she's pleased about his
compliment if you did choose a and your
clinician think again
be she's pleased about his compliment
that's a under mentalizing response she
kind of looks pleased but there's more
to her facial expression I think you
would agree there's more ambivalence in
her facial expression so yes if you're a
clinician you took you chose B think
again see she's exasperated about
Michael coming on too strong so where
the other two are no mentalizing and
under mentalizing we call this hyper
mentalizing that's making more of the
situation than what is in the data so
this is over interpreting I'll come back
to this a lot of a lot of the time the
rest of the talk will focus a lot on
hyper mentalizing but this is the hyper
mentalizing response D of course then
she's flattered but someone taken by
surprise that would be the accurate
mentalizing response so all of you that
are clinicians and got that one right
you are can feel confident that you're a
good mental Iser so when we then use
this variety of tasks in research with
borderline patients we do see deficits
or impairment in mentalization I've just
kind of listed out a few of these and
for you there's a lot of good reviews
out there that summarizes the
mentalization impairment in borderline
personality disorder so first of all
alterations in emotion recognition which
is subsumed under the broad umbrella of
mentalization negative bias towards or a
bias towards negative emotions when
reading the faces of other people in
terms of verbal descriptions of other
mental states borderline patients
sometimes show impairment error patterns
in facial recognition have been shown in
morphing studies where a facial
expression changes from neutral to
another expression borderline patients
seem to have a slight bias towards anger
expressions in multimodal studies
borderline patients have been found to
show their biggest impairment and this
is when they have to deal like in the
mask the movie assessment for social
cognition they have to deal with a lot
of information at the same time facial
expressions what people are saying the
narrative of what is happening when
there's a lot of information in the task
board
patience seemed to struggle the most the
less information is in a task the better
they do in fact in some tasks like the
ice taste where they just have to
recognize emotion expressions from the
region of the eyes borderline patients
actually surpass this and healthy
controls so more information there is
the bigger the impairment this these
alterations and emotion recognition have
been done really extended to adolescents
there's been fairly good data showing
that adolescents seem to have the same
problems when they have BPD traits and
then in mentalization proper we do see
using these classic mentalization tasks
and the fo part tasks and empathy a
Hariri for instance showed impairment in
cognitive but not effective theory of
mind using the mask Chrysler and all you
showed in payments in theory of mind a
Dickson Gordon showed in a really good
study how when the effect of arousal
like Arrieta spoke about this morning
when the effect of arousal goes up the
mentalization goes down so in a lot of
borderline patients you don't see
mentalization being unimpaired until the
attachment system is activated and the
arousal goes up and then in a fMRI study
very nicely was illustrated hypo
activation of the Marine euro system
which is considered to be a
mentalization circuit but hyper
activation of the amygdala symptom again
as the arousal goes up in the task and
then in our own work we have focused on
hyper mentalizing so what we've done was
we've showed the mask to adolescents
with BPD and adolescence without BPD
psychiatric controls and what we found
was that borderline adolescents
typically chose the hyper mentalizing
response and that was for us an exciting
finding because there's been mixed
findings for mentalization in borderline
but a lot of the studies would not
request research participants to
actually choose between no mentalizing
low mentalizing and hyper mentalizing
but when you actually give those options
to patients with borderline they tend to
go for
the hyper mentalizing response and so
this is just a little bit of data that
shows that and I'm just going to draw
your attention to the BBFS see that's
our borderline kraits measure for
adolescence and as you go down to the
total correct mentalizing
you can see a negative correlation so as
borderline traits go up correct
mentalizing goes down hyper mentalizing
at 41 that's a very high correlation and
no correlations with no mentalizing or
less mentalizing
so we in this study tried to suggest
that really the deficit in BPD is one of
hyper mentalizing rather than one of no
mentalizing or under mentalizing and i'm
going to talk more about hyper
mentalizing
shortly we put this into two regression
analysis the take-home message here is
here we have borderline traits as the
dependent variable here we have
diagnosis we know there's a debate or
whether we should look at this from a
trade based view or from a diagnostic
point of view so we tested it both ways
and we controlled for externalizing and
internalizing problems we did that to
make sure that the finding we're getting
is not due to other psychopathology we
know that BPD is very comorbid with
other psychopathology we still had the
hyper mentalizing finding so that's the
Tyco message there so starting to then
fill out this translational model for
BPD here I want to draw your attention
into hyper mentalizing this is the
contribution we've been making a lot of
in terms of the neurocognitive in the
phenotype this is alongside many other
mentalization neurocognitive in the
phenotypes that research has shown
anomalous emotion recognition reduced
trust decisions hyper mentalizing
alexithymia problems in metacognitive
capacity social cognitive biases and
rejection sensitivity so moving on the
integration of biology so what I've done
here you've got the the the nine
symptoms that Emily also presented at
the beginning of the day there are
several genes that have been identified
to be affected in BPD that's also
related to mental izing capacity so the
basics
scientists who do genetic research on
social cognition and mentalization have
identified some genes that are
associated with poorer or better
mentalization capacity and it turns out
that many of those genes are also
associated with BPD the same with the
neurobiological in the phenotype reduced
ACC activation amygdala activation which
I talked about earlier reduced orbital
frontal cortex activation these are in
response to theory of mind
tasks and we know that they're also
affected in BPD patients I'm going to
just stand still a little bit at this
one reduced insular activation this is a
study where we use this behavioral
economic tasks from basic science and we
gave this task to BPD patients and
healthy controls in the tasks there is
an investor and a trustee the investor
gets twenty dollars the investor needs
to decide how many of those he or she
well it was all female studies so how
many of the $20 she wanted to share with
her with the trustee the trustee the
trustee was anonymous in this case
whatever gets sent to the trustee is
tripled on the way so if I have $20 and
I decide to give ten dollars to you you
will have $30 you then get to decide how
much Mahomet how many of those you want
to sing back to the trustee and this
game is play ten times over so if you
think about it what needs to happen is
we need to build trust across these ten
rounds if I as the investor I'm gonna
give you a low offer of $2 you gonna not
trust me and feel a little bit hurt by
the fact that I'm only sharing two am i
keep eighteen dollars but it's in the
investors it's in to the benefit of the
investor to actually invest that money
because it's tripled so if the invest
reinvest the investor has more
likelihood of getting money back so it's
really a very delicate game across thin
rounds to build trust so what happens
when borderline patients play this guy
so what happens naturally in this game
is that there are low offers sometimes
the investor keeps $15 and only invest
$5 that's a that's a low offer gets trip
up tripled of course so the trustee now
a $15 so what can the trustee do and I
want you to throw flicked a little bit
on what you typically do just for fun
but one of the things that healthy
controls do in that situation is they
coke cokes they partner back into the
game so they get a low offer and instead
of walking off and a half they decide
you know I'm gonna send a signal to my
partner saying that I want to be friends
hey what what what are you doing you're
giving me five dollars I'm gonna give
you back everything I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you back
everything and send a signal hey let's
be friends come the next round give me
more money
that's what healthy controls end up
doing in the game the borderline
patients do not cokes in the game what
we found across the ten rounds is that
if you invest a few cokes you get more
repayment on the next round here we see
the difference between borderline
patients and healthy controls in terms
of coaxing behavior turns out that
coaxing is associated with insular
activity in the brain so this is the
healthy controls here these insular
activity in the brain that's associated
with coaxing behavior and you see that's
absent in the borderline patients so if
you will the insula has a lot of jobs in
the brain but one of the jobs of the
insula is to tell you in our
interpretation of this data that these
are break in the relationship there's a
rupture in the relationship and you need
to repair and borderline patients in
this study did not show that insular
activation so we busy filling out this
translational spectrum and we are trying
to find a neural network component of
variable that can explain borderline
patients behavior and this is one
example of that here we see this also
related to interpersonal trusts course
borderline patients just when you ask
them so looking at the behavioral
phenotype when you ask borderline
patients do what do you trust your
partner they tend to say or have lowest
scores and what they invested in their
partners was also at the behavioral
level less so trying to connect again
the behavior to what's going on in the
brain and later on to what's going on in
session which we will get to all right
the next criteria so so far just to
recap translational research needs to be
multidisciplinary it needs to work from
bedside to bench and from bench to
bedside I've tried to show those two
criteria the biological component needs
to be integrated in a meaningful way
fourth translational research works best
when it's developmental as you heard
this morning from aria
Arrieta mentalization based approach is
but in its essence developmental and I
like to show this model which Peter
phone again Patrick Lydon published in
2009 and development of development in
psychopathology because it really kind
of captures the mentalization based
theory very nicely and how it leads to
to BPD so here you've got your nine
criteria and you have distal factors
it's a developmental psychopathology
model so you've got distal factors and
proximal factors that interact with each
other at the distal point you have
attachment disruptions which are Yetta
spoke about very nicely this morning as
well as constitutional factors which we
heard very nicely from Francesca this
morning sensitive children children who
are sensitive and they are in an
attachment relationship where a parent
for whatever reason cannot respond to to
the intensity and the sensitivity of the
child and we have these attachment
disruptions which then leads to a poor
self other differentiation
hypersensitivity to the mental states of
others constantly scanning other people
what are other people thinking about me
trying to control other people to think
certain things about them low threshold
for active attachment activation
and controlled mentalization the
activation within payments in
integration of cognition and effect so
the central the central engine here that
then keeps BPD going and leading to
these pre mentalizing modes of social
cognition what are the pre mentalizing
modes of social cognition
they are pretend mode Breton mode sounds
like mentalizing but it isn't
mentalizing so a good example of a
preteen mode would be when you have a
person trying to be empathic but it's
really coming out of a place of
manipulation in order to get a certain
behavior from another person so if you
go by mental state language it sounds
like a mentalization but it really isn't
if you dig a little bit deeper and see
it in context that's pretend mode
psychic equivalents is a confusion
between what's in my mind and what's
really happening out there
so believing it's a little bit like we
find in OCD where there's thought action
a merge where what is happening is real
rather than I have a mind that is
separate from what is happening out
there and I can dissociate the two and
then finally teleological mode which is
really just goal oriented behavior so
again taking the mind out of the
equation and just focusing on the
behavior so those are the three pre
mentalizing modes of social cognition
and that then keeps the the symptoms
going so this is to illustrate to you
that mentalization is by nature a
developmental approach it's also
developmental in the sense that it's got
a normative map charted out full
mentalization based development it's
best charted out for preschoolers that's
just one of the maps that are out there
and there is data now for adolescents as
well it obviously gets a little bit more
complicated in adolescence and young
adulthood but this process is not
complete until people reach they
twenties so then this criteria then that
translational research works best when
it's developmental we see again
potential for mentalization to meet this
criterion does mentalization have the
capacity to accommodate mediators and
moderators one of the most important
mediators is emotion dysregulation so in
our study that i talked about earlier we
did look at emotion dysregulation
through the difficulties in emotion
regulation scale and we found that hyper
mentalizing effects BPD through emotion
dysregulation so you can imagine that a
person hyper mental Isis gets more
effective effectively aroused it becomes
harder for them to regulate their
emotions and the BPD symptom levels go
up so that's in terms of mediators there
of course other mediators that is going
to affect mentalization research has
shown stress reactivity experiential
avoidance will affect mentalization
identity diffusion will affect
mentalization
moderators known moderators of
methylation capacity is gender I just do
the women wanna guess who's better at
mentalizing age is a moderator
maltreatment is a moderator of
mentalization and then family variables
and I'm just gonna give you a taste of
that again so in this study we just did
we add it to our model attachment so we
did child attachment interviews with our
adolescents and here you can see this is
the attachment coherence upscale you can
see a high negative correlation with
hyper mentalizing as hyper mentalizing
goes up attachment coherence goes down
and in the way that this is measured in
the CII of course we coded by by looking
at how coherent lee someone can make
sense of the experiences with the
attachment figure and you can see here
then a BP FAC of course again borderline
traits associated with
with with hyper mentalizing as well as
emotion dysregulation and when we put
that into a multiple mediation or model
you see this very nice model here where
hyper mentalizing is again mediating the
relationship between attachment security
and borderline features emotion
dysregulation and this model did not do
that probably because of the
relationship between these two variables
all right so moving on to the next
criterion so yes we've got all this
basic science in support of the
mentalization construct now can we take
this construct and translate it into a
malleable treatment target so what we've
done is to review all of this literature
on on BPD and mentalization and it is
mixed and we've distilled these four
characterizations of mentalization that
we find in BPD in order to try and
develop a treatment target if we need to
say what are we going to target in
mentalization based therapy what should
it be
so we first of all came up with the
conclusion that social cognitive
deficits are apparent under high
conditions of high arousal so if a
borderline patient is not necessarily
highly aroused though they may be an
excellent mental Iser or even a superior
mental Iser and you have heard people
talk about the borderline paradox where
clinicians have reported on how
wonderfully sensitive borderline
patients can be in interpersonal
situations at the moment the attachment
as the attachment relationship is
activated or attachment contexts
activated an arousal goes up
mentalization goes down next social
cognitive deficits are apparent only
under conditions that require
integration across different cognitive
modalities like I said before in simple
tasks borderline patients do really
really well it's when things get
complicated and integration across
cognitive and affective modalities
across self and other the space between
two people once that starts happening it
gets more difficult for patients with
BPD to mentalize social cognitive
deficits and BP reflect a lack of
integration between these social
cognitive systems and individuals with
BPD therefore do
suffer from deficits per se it's not
that like autistic individuals I can't
mental eyes it is that there is an over
attribution when the effect gets aroused
which we then call hyper mentalizing so
we've just put it all in a visual
representation with The Associated
literature so a person gets into
emotionally intense interpersonal event
it leads to a lack of integration across
cognitive modalities a reliance on
controlled explicit social cognitive
reasoning when the gut needs to be
relied on or sometimes a rely reliance
on the gut when the person needs to be
actively engaging in controlled
mentalization so it's a lack of fit
between what the social situation is
asking me to do with what my brain is
doing which leads to errors in
interpretation and then hyper
mentalizing alright so how do we define
hyper mentalizing excessive theory of
mind is how it was originally defined by
diabaté could develop the mask or social
cognitive processing that involves
making assumptions about other people's
mental states that go so far beyond
observable data that the average
observer will struggle to see how they
are justified or over attribution of
mental states to others and they likely
Musante misinterpretation or over active
and exaggerated resonance with the
mental states of others due to confusion
between self and other mental states all
right what does it sound like in
practice so remember we're trying to get
through this whole translational
spectrum for mentalization this comes
out of SUNY beau Hanson he's a Danish
psychiatrist working with mentalization
based therapists therapy so the
therapist says so tell me about the
difficult situation when you met with
your ex-boyfriend this is a 17 year old
girl that he treated it seems to me that
it was a bit frustrating for you to meet
with him is that right to put it that
way
Gena says he met with me just to see
that I was still in pain the therapist
said what was it like to meet with him
Gina says awful I mean I spent two hours
in hell he kept telling me about his
life and that he's going out and has a
lot of new friends so annoying I hate
him and he doesn't respect me just wants
to bug me therapist says that doesn't
sound nice did you feel anything in
particular in that situation Gina says I
[ __ ] told you I hating what is it
that you don't get Gina talks very loud
and she seems agitated the therapist
says wow it seems to me that you are
affected with what happened here sorry
it wasn't my intention to annoy you Gina
says you all say you were sorry but it
is a lie she talks loud and fast John
the ex-boyfriend says he is sorry that
we could not stay together [ __ ] he's
not sorry about anything Lisa the
contact person at the institution says
she wants to help me and tries to
understand me all the time she's not
trying to understand anything or help
anybody you and all that mentalizing the
therapist said hold on hold on for a
second Gina this is going really fast
and I can't figure this all out
can we please pause for a second and
look at what happened here and then Gina
says I don't want to pause anything I
know what you're up to you want to blame
me tell me that it's my own fault that I
have to work with myself that we should
try and look at it together she makes a
face no way you obviously don't want to
help me that is clear you just want to
talk I need action action teleological
mode Lisa doesn't like me I know for a
fact there you see psychic equivalents
and Carl head of the institution ignores
me on purpose and then Gina starts to
cry and so you can see that she's in
this pretend mode she is there's a
there's a lack of what is really in the
mind of the therapist right now and she
is ascribing thoughts to the therapist
and intentions to the therapist that the
therapist does not have at that moment
and so a clinical example of of hyper
mentalizing so can we talk at this
disease mechanism if it's a disease
mechanism one of many disease mechanisms
in BPD can we target it in in treatment
so what we did here is we took the mass
and we gave it alongside a bunch of
other mentalization measures because we
interested in seeing is it is it hyper
mentalizing really which which is the
thing we need to target so this is a
vignettes task this is an empathy task
someone asked earlier about what's the
difference between empathy and
realization this is an empathy task and
this is the eyes test and on the map of
mentalization implicit explicit
mentalization automatic controlled
memorization internal and external
features that won't focus on a
mentalization you can see they all lie
on a different place for in terms of the
mentalizing landscape what we found was
really that it was really only this one
that were sensitive to treatment so it
could be a property of the task that's
possible but it could also be that it is
hyper mentalizing which is what we
reduce in our therapy whether we do DBT
or whether it is we do may MBT or
anything else it is a hyper mentalizing
how we address so here we just see
simply a reduction in for both BPD and
non BPD adolescents in hyper mentalizing
we did a very simple thing which was
just to correlate the change in hyper
mentalizing and BPD features and they
were highly correlated so we concluded
through just this inpatient treatment
that we do at the meaning of clinic we
are bringing down - mentalizing and we
doing so at a higher rate for borderline
kids than non borderline kids all right
on - can we capture the behavioral
phenotype so we got a treatment target
that we think we may target thoughtfully
can we capture it or do we need to go do
fMRI tasks to capture it or the mask
which takes a long time forty-five
minutes when you run through the whole
mask can we capture it in any other way
so we've been working on developing a
hyper mentalizing measure we've
identified five components over concern
with the mental states of others over
interpretation of other mental states
inflexible certainty in own beliefs
about others mental states acting
impulsively on assumed mental states of
others and second-guessing or over
interpretation of own mental states here
are just some of the examples so and
importantly we do this in the attachment
context so adhering to the model of
attached
based mentalizing we do this in the
attachment context I worry a lot a lot
about what my parents are thinking and
feeling over interpretation my parents
often say I over interpret into personal
situations with him inflexible certainty
my feelings about my parents are
thinking it's hardly ever wrong acting
impulsively I easily lose control in
situations with my parents if my
feelings get hurt second-guessing I
often feel angry at my parents because I
feel confused about my own feelings and
we've got a parent version
boyfriend/girlfriend version and a
closest friend version so we've done
this in two studies now with 690
undergraduates just to get a feel for it
we did the masks these the theory of my
test that I showed you earlier and we
expected a negative correlation with
correct mentalizing a positive
correlation with excessively mentalizing
and no correlation with least on all
note on because it's supposed to be the
hyper mentalizing component of
mentalizing we did acceptance and
mindfulness emotion dysregulation poor
reflective function we accept expected
people to be pure emotion dysregulation
and acceptance and Porat reflective
function when the scores in hyper
mentalizing
were high this is just basic
psychometrics we which were good for the
measure and here's the construct
validity so if you just go down number 4
which is the hyper mentalizing you see
exactly what was expected for correct
mentalizing the negative correlation
excessive theory theory of mind is
uniquely correlating with it not the
other two subscales of the experimental
task and then the expected directions
with experiential avoidance emotion
dysregulation and reflective function so
we were encouraged by this finding
within oh let me quickly just show you
this is just the data for and the
romantic closest friend and appearance
and what came out of these correlations
is that we think the parent version of
this in adolescence is probably going to
be the most robust or valid so if you
have to choose between the three
versions it's probably going to be the
parent one that is going to give you
most bang for your buck in terms of BPD
in study two we then took this to the
adolescent population thirty-five
adolescents meeting DSM criteria for BPD
forty
psychiatric controls without BPD and 83
healthy controls we did the CI BPD
diagnostic interview for borderline and
then the hyper mentalizing and here's
just a grand total and you can see this
very nice pattern with the healthy
controls lowest on hyper mentalizing
other disorders do hyper mental eyes -
you get the psychiatric controls and the
borderline kids are highest and that's a
cross romantic partner parents and
closest friends so again encouraging
result that we can capture this
behavioral phenotype in this
translational spectrum we don't have to
go do fMRI or genetics analysis but we
can potentially capture something that
relates to all of those other levels of
analysis that we've been looking at so
there's the full model then in terms of
what I've been talking about I want us
to then just get to MBT so closing the
loop many of you are familiar with it's
a collaborative approach formulation you
want to in the therapy help patients
identify when they are in a non
mentalizing mode the general stance is a
one in which you are constantly
monitoring effective arousal because we
know that if the effect of arousal gets
too high then you'll have to bring the
effect of arousal down in order to
effectively do the mentalization by
therapy and I'm going to show you a
little video where you see Anthony
Bateman doing that rather ineffectively
Anthony wanted me to say that to you so
like we know myth the core of
mentalization basis is a stance of
curiosity so not knowing stance you are
not the wise one in immunization based
therapy but it is collaborative and you
are working things out in the context of
the relationship with the patient as you
go along identification of the
mentalization pulls and then there's a
predict trajectory of sessions and that
start off more structured and gets less
structured and more relationship focus
as you go along
specific strategies just for hyper
mentalizing because i'm busy really
focusing on that for the treatment
target
retained mode then ideas form no breach
between the inner and outer reality the
mental world is decoupled from the
external reality dissociation of thought
hyper mentalizing or pseudo mentalizing
reflects the explicit mentalizing being
dominated by implicit inadequate
internal focus pure belief desire
reasoning and vulnerability to fusion
with others and this is managed by
interrupting the non mentalizing process
so encourage the patient to step back
from this collapsing reminded me of
Francesca's stop stay back we call it
pause and rewind stay back from this
collapsing of appearance and reality
drawing attention to the patient's
vulnerability to emotional contagion
drawing attention to their difficulty in
inserting doubt or uncertainty into the
process of inference health the patient
integrate in ten scenes of effective
knowledge and with more reflective and
cognitive knowledge the aim for the
integration of cognitive belief states
which are dominated by the agent and
effective knowledge which is dominated
by the inferences drawn by their feeling
so again just get the poles integrated
again between self and other effects and
cognition work towards shifting the
patient's thoughts and feelings between
the self and the other in a consistent
flexible way and differentiation between
self and others
is this working this is working there we
go how it compares to things like
personalization or catastrophizing
whether there are certain red flags or
kind of buzz words related to thoughts
that are suggestive perhaps of hyper
mentalizing that someone's like
well I do think there is a connection
and I was I was psychodynamic Ukraine in
South Africa before I then moved to
England and there I was trained as a CBT
therapist and I've always the idea of
hyper mentalizing always resonated for
me with the idea of mind-reading so we
in CBT we tell people one of the one of
the cognitive distortions that people
engages is mind-reading and we've often
thought about that in the context of
social anxiety so people with social
anxiety tend to mind-read they're
constantly scanning other people for
what they might be thinking and
tributing thoughts to them I think it's
exactly the same I don't think I think
it's useful to use CBT I think for me
really we don't have to box in the
therapeutic modalities like we've done
in the past I think there's a lot of
overlap and what what perhaps is new is
thinking that borderline patients
mind-read I think we in the past thought
that borderline patients don't read
minds but they do but they just overeat
minds although it would be to me - too
many mental states to other people yeah
thank you there's any difference between
mentalizing well you know I do think
there is a slight difference in the
sense that I think the outcomes the same
I think
mentalization will validate when you are
but but the difference is that
metallization it takes the stance of
curiosity so you're not really saying
that that that that is really hard I
would have cried too if that happened to
me you are just saying oh boy what what
what were you thinking the I mean how
did you handle that what I don't know
what I would have done but what did you
do or what will you think what were you
feeling so it's a it's a curious stance
rather than immediately validating it
because it comes out of the idea that we
we buy by getting the patient to reflect
themselves on on
on their own mind and and what was
happening in situation in the mind of
the other you can you can get movement
doing I think in the end both will will
validate the patient so they may be some
overlap thee but I think in DBT there's
perhaps a clearer immediate validation
happening we can ask a liqueur or
Francesca we use diagnostically there's
no data to that we've just developed a
measure this year the masks people have
been using it in clinical practice in
order to just get a sense of people's
mentalizing style it's complicated
because you have to get the mission from
the developer and there's no norms so I
think part of evaluating mentalization
as a translational construct is the
development of off-the-shelf measures
and that's what we're trying to do to
create norms and see whether we can use
these measures in clinical practice to
either you know identify someone style
but also then importantly to see if
there's a reduction in in that style
over time there's been one RCT conducted
by Trudy Russo and Peter Funaki that was
published was a 2012 in the orange
journal order American Academy of Child
Alistair Gayatri and so that's the RCT
that's been published there's a couple
of other groups across different
countries that have been doing
maintenance work for adolescents I'm a
co-investigator on a trial that we're
now doing in Houston so I think there'll
be more data coming out but the only RCT
that's out there right now is the one
with Trudy Rizzo so it's Russo and fawn
a key I think 2012 and folks who want
that can email me for that okay
perhaps it's the after lunch experience
we those are our questions
sure thank you very much you'll be
joining us again on the panel if other
people have questions or come up